[Música]
en las zonas del noreste de Siria
controladas por la oposición al gobierno
la población quedó desamparada tras el
terremoto del pasado 6 de febrero ante
el elevado número de víctimas y la falta
de recursos rápidamente fueron cavadas
fosas comunes
o más alta
terminar en los días posteriores al
terremoto estuvimos en contacto con
nuestros observadores que se encuentran
en estas zonas prácticamente aisladas
donde la población carece de lo más
básico zaidal Side es voluntario en los
campamentos de desplazados internos de
adme donde los últimos años se han
concentrado cientos de miles de sirios
que huyen de la guerra civil said fue
testigo de la excavación de una fosa
común estas 30 personas fallecidas
tenían familiares que vivían en el
campamento pertenecen al mismo clan Es
la primera vez que se excava una fosa
como una K no fueron trasladados al
hospital porque todos los hospitales
están llenos son sus familiares que
están ayudando a identificarlos Quienes
fueron al lugar de los hechos muchos de
los desplazados por el conflicto en
Siria viven en tiendas de campaña y
resultaron relativamente ilesos tras el
terremoto pero en el noreste del país
muchos de los que habían conseguido
instalarse en apartamentos murieron ya
sin musaf es un activista que suele
desplazarse entre las zonas afectadas
por el terremoto
cuando las familias sacan a sus
parientes de entre los escombros lo
llevan a los hospitales solo para
comprobar si están vivos o muertos
luego se lo llevan para enterrarlos
los equipos de la defensa civil y los
voluntarios han cavado varias fosas
comunes
estas fosas secaban a lo largo para
enterrar a la mayor cantidad de personas
normalmente el mismo pueblo estas
personas son enterradas juntas son
enterradas de prisa porque los equipos
de rescate están desbordados y tienen
que atender a otras víctimas
Lamentablemente
en la tradición musulmana el entierro de
un cadáver va precedido de un ritual que
implica un lavado y luego una oración
dada las circunstancias muchas víctimas
fueron enterradas directamente sin
ninguna ceremonia funeraria lo que
muchas familias dicen sentir como un
doble dolor
[Música]
lo que están viendo es real Este es un
tigre grabado por una cámara de
seguridad en medio de una zona
Residencial al noreste de johannesburgo
las imágenes resultan sorprendentes
sobre todo porque en Sudáfrica no hay
Tigres en estado salvaje
dwayneth es el propietario del lugar
donde fue visto el tigre y obviamente no
se esperaba despertar con algo así mi
conductor me llamó a las 5:50 de la
mañana y me dijo que había un tigre en
el patio
desde luego no le
creím pero salió y dio movimiento
el primer ángulo de la cámara pensamos
que quizás era un león o algo así
un perro grande porque las primeras
imágenes no eran claras entonces
cambiamos el ángulo de la cámara
obviamente estábamos sorprendidos y no
lo creíamos la historia podría resultar
insólita si no fuera porque una tigresa
ya había sido vista paseando a
principios de enero también en
johannesburgo se llamaba durante días y
mató a varios animales e hirió a un
hombre antes de que su dueño le
disparara esta tigresa procedía de un
criadero algo Bastante habitual en
Sudáfrica donde a veces crían leones y
tigres de forma intensiva algunos
criaderos los venden después en mercados
asiáticos y la aparición de estos dos
Tigres en una zona urbana fue una buena
ocasión para que los defensores de
derechos de los animales alertaran sobre
las condiciones de estos criaderos
escuche lo que dice Sara Luke de la
asociación Ford post creemos que existen
vínculos entre la industria de los
grandes felinos exóticos y la industria
de las mascotas exóticas
no estamos hablando de una ardilla que
uno ve en un parque son animales que no
son nativos de Sudáfrica
eso significa que alguien debe estar
criándolos en cautiverio con un fin
específico
en las grandes instalaciones nuestras
investigaciones han demostrado que el
bienestar animal no es una prioridad
y que el estándar de las normas de
bienestar de los animales cautivos no es
alto
el beneficio económico es el verdadero
motor de estos criaderos no es el
bienestar de los animales que pasa a un
segundo plano y esa es nuestra principal
preocupación se pueden ver en las peores
condiciones se pueden ver animales esto
ha sido ampliamente documentado con
mucha sarna cosas así incluso
deformidades físicas porque puede haber
endogamia
en algunas provincias sudafricanas no se
requiere una licencia para poseer un
tigre Como por ejemplo en la región en
la que fueron vistos estos dos tigres el
país es el mayor exportador mundial de
grandes felinos tanto de animales vivos
como de partes de su cuerpo Sudáfrica a
menudo es criticada por sus laxas
políticas en materia de cría de animales
exóticos
Gracias a todos nuestros observadores
que nos comparten estos temas en
imágenes y videos aficionados usted
presenció algún acontecimiento envíenos
sus testimonios y archivos a través de
los contactos que aparecen en sus
pantallas hasta la próxima semana